we'll get five suggestions five random
topics and then i will freestyle rap
about those five random topics if you
are sat in this area here what would you
like a wrap about a pogo stick a pogo
stick thank you very much are you a keen
pogo enthusiast
used to be yeah no it's a thing you grow
out of isn't it really
matt you you're eight showing up to a
park with a pogo stick everyone leaves
everyone goes pogo sticker pogo stick
what would you guys like to wrap about
professional baseball player
professional baseball player thank you
very much what do you have against
amateur baseball players
we can't talk about it you in like
baseball witness protection what is it
okay cool the the professional baseball
player middle of the room see what she's
done there she's trying to trick me
because she thinks i don't know anything
about baseball and she is correct
baseball is like um
noisy cricket i think
people in the middle of the room what
would you like a rap about
a fit bird so that's british see
americans are confused
yeah ah there we go yeah there we go in
english slang it means an attractive
lady isn't that quite fun that in our
slang a fit bird is equal to a hot chick
it's both avian
that's weird isn't it
in australia they call it a [ __ ]
[Music]
baseball player a fit bird people in
this triangular wedge here what do you
want to rap about honest people there
were so many what was that one
amish people amish people and what was
the other one jello jello cool amish
people and jellos
it's going to blow their minds
people over here watch it like a wrap up
final one
mushrooms oh as in as in the the
psychedelic
things
sounds like you weren't aware until now
okay cool someone who doesn't know that
mushrooms have psychotropic effects
cool this is this is what we've got
we've got those suggestions right have
to find the little cable
here ah look at you thank you very much
what a civic duty you just did there
just an older mature man just being like
there for the rap that you're going to
do that i will definitely despise
so the topics to remind you we got a
pogo stick professional baseball player
a fit bird amish people and jello and
mushrooms oh my god what you can trip on
mushrooms i didn't know that uh that's
what we're we're gonna do let's drop
this beat let's have some fun
[Music]
it won't be ho-hum me oh my we're gonna
talk about the little fungi get high in
the kitchen there'd be nothing that i
love less over there working out a
fungus chef i'll be chopping them up i
got my portobello usually day to day
life really mellow some type of fellow
who gets my button i chop them up there
but wait i've forgotten i was steeping
some in the corner you can see tiny
little pot i'll be brewing the tea and
then i take it on a camping trip with me
i go mushroom soup oh you pee i'm gonna
take a tiny little cup knock it back
share it with my friends then i feel an
anxiety attack i'm like [ __ ] what is
this i feel like time and space is
basically ripped so my friend says yo
you're on a trip it's [ __ ] cool just
kick back let it rip i never realized
why does it do this to me i call my
doctor ah anxiety and my doctor's like
what the [ __ ] are you so confused like a
five-year-old who's never even used a
mushroom
throw up make yourself sick like an
enematic jumping on a pogo stick that's
the trick i'm about in there up and down
maybe use this little mime thing that i
found oh yay
oh it's the fun thing in the playground
like a stick with a spring and the tiny
little place where you rest your feet
when it comes to fun sticks yeah it
can't be beat pogo yo yo it's a much
worse toy baseball [ __ ] it i'm ever so
annoyed and if you're employed the lady
likes you but if you make no cash she
won't invite you to a picnic she's like
get a big stick hit the ball when it
comes swerving quick if you're not
mickey mantle or babe ruth you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] get out of here that's the
honest truth she wouldn't tell me why
that she prefers professional
baseballers to the amateurs probably
because you wanna suck their dick i
don't know are you a fit bird or a hot
chick who can even tell shadows on the
face when you're [ __ ] the baseball
are you stealing first base or even
second is that the phrase that they used
a fit bird oh yeah a lot to do you
walking over there lovely little tees
coming over there in london city i'm a
cockney you can suck my balls it'd be
ever so lovely as they jiggle i washed
them recently so they're not smelly they
move a little bit like the motion of
jelly it's charmless to rap about this
but harmless i'm off there
see some amish they walk to me and say
chris now you said the jelly would make
us go wow botanically it's made with
gelatin from a cow and we raise these
bovine animals now and so jello in the
amish community they eat weekly yet
consume with impunity
[Applause]